insidious was a movie I had no plans on
seeing because a scary movie has to be
really good for me to enjoy it if a
scary movie is done well I love it it's
actually my favorite genre of film but
only if it's done well because there are
so many scary movies that are just just
awful so it's hard for me to actually
call it my favorite genre because
technically it's not because literally
about 70% of them just don't really work
out what I really like is good suspense
I don't care about blood and gore that's
not scary that's just gross this is
directed by James Wan and he's the guy
who started the Saw franchise he also
directed movie called dead silence which
I have not seen and death sentence which
I have not seen I'm so skeptical about
scary movies because they have to be
like really good this is films about a
boy who suddenly goes into a coma and
everyone kind of is telling him that
he's in some coma but they can't really
explain what it is and as various creepy
things start to happen in this house
this couple who has the son seeks out
specialists and whatnot in the begin to
think that the son might be trapped in
another dimension and beings that exist
in that dimension are basically scaring
the crap out of everyone insidious is
one of the scariest movies I have ever
seen this movie scared the crap out of
me and I'm not even talking about the
stupid jump scares this movie has those
oh my word it has them but this movie
gave me goosebumps multiple times like
there were images in this movie stuff
that happened that just literally sent
goosebumps down my spine like just
absolute insanity there was literally
multiple times in this movie
right as when seriously Patrick Wilson
plays the father and Rose Byrne plays
the mother of this child and they are
both very good and then one of the
reasons that movie worked so well is
because they bring a realism to their
characters amidst all of the various
things that are obviously over the top
and you know could easily come off as
laughable but because they make it seem
so real it really works very well and I
cannot honestly give enough praise James
Wan for this movie because I've never
actually seen one of his films his
direction for this film was so
suspenseful just absolutely exactly how
I would have done it if I made this film
and that alone I was just so pleased
with that because there are no cheap
scares in this film never once does a
person approach a closet door slowly and
open it and a cat jumps out or something
stupid never once does a human form
should have to be some strange broom
with a coat on it behind a curtain or
something all the scares in this movie
are completely legit and that is norther
another one of the reasons why I liked
it because there's never a moment where
you think something's about to be scary
and you're like it always just happens
the trailers make this movie not to seem
like a cliched haunted house movie no it
is not like that at all it's completely
different it's nothing like that at all
they're trying to make it seem that way
so they can sell it you know what I mean
to the audience as one of those average
you know movies like that no it has a
lot more to offer trust me I'm going to
be 23 here in a few weeks and I'm
sitting there in the theater all bundled
up with my legs all up like this and
just like staring at the screen and
there were a few times I wanted to be
like but I didn't I looked and sidious
was very frightening the acting was very
good the direction was good
all the characters did a really good job
of being believable amidst you know all
these crazy situations happening the use
of real images in this film and not
using you know stupid special effects to
get scared they use real things you know
just they did a really good job with
that the score for this film is so
creepy and so loud and intense and well
done I'm going to give it sidious four
out of four stars my highest rating I
can't believe I'm saying that because
you know it just looked like an average
shocker movie but no no this film is
made so well and I was so impressed so
creepy and very fun very well made this
movie frightened me so much I am not
even kidding I have no problem admitting
this movies scared me to death if you're
looking for a good scare you have found
your movie